hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to playtime now I've been
going down the rabbit hole of these
pixelated horror games and I don't want
to miss out on any good ones and there's
a scary clown in this one so if you got
a fear of clowns well buckle up buddy
you're about to get a but blasphemous
buckle up buddy you're gonna have some
clowns Adam maybe it's not clowns
could not be clowns you know you never
know with these things I don't know hi
it's clowns okay it's definitely it's
clowns let's play a game open the door
and escape oh it's an escape room but
there's a catch okay all right
I've send some of my friends over there
make sure they don't see your light ah
good
why oftime what does off-time mean hello
Honka why don't--you're no squonk
why don't you squonk he knows shooting
seems to be closed oh if it seems to be
closed
use your seeming brain to make it open
hello where'd you go cloudy boo I could
break something with this why why could
you break something with that it's a
rubber ball what are you gonna do with
the goddamn rubber ball oh can I break
you with this hey smash oh you're a
bouncy boy ain't ya oh look at the
bouncy boy okay goodbye then the [ __ ] is
this dippy steps okay push the button
don't know why booster Boonton hello ah
good blood handprint or hand person with
legs I can't tell which any of these
books ring a bell any of these books
ping pong a Pell Palmer and oh hi ah
cheap jump scares great I knew that I
would like this game it's right up my
alley okay oh god I gotta go through
this bill let me pick up your baby here
and drop him off into the abyss of
forever push that button and take this
barrel can I break your face whoa didn't
expect that to do nothing I got a toy
knife I've seen oh you're still talking
somehow I don't
that's a bad sound okay so I don't know
how to make them not see my light oh hi
okay I got a candle oh maybe it is
something inside my knife on that
well the crows were appreciative of that
maneuver oh hi I saw something oh hi
okay I don't know why I did that
okay all right no ah shitty tits hi
buddy how you doing
[ __ ] okay so I think I know what I gotta
do is gonna be a relatively simple game
hey take some of this in your face right
now oh boy do that I'll take you move
you push that Scratchy's on those and
nothing is there a way to like turn off
the flashlight so I don't have to deal
with is there a way to turn that off off
time there's got to be a way to turn
that off right well just gonna have to
push a beer like the badass that is
[Music]
space ah I only get a certain amount of
time well in a certain amount of time
only dad a bunch of wonky bunker no one
told me that I needed to press bio buddy
goodbye see you then all right
fare thee well go have luck on your
advantage or flashpoint okay turn off
that appeared nothing in the K but now
yeah it's missing a handle how about a
candle for the handle okay then how
about a candle for the by ox no okay how
about a candle light Oh lit the candle
on fire okay that's good I don't know
what that day boom
didn't see no clown do nope no clowns
here need a candle candle hmm missing a
handle handle for the handle handle
candle candle handle banal gamble put
the candle in the handle urn the
bookshelf down burn the infidels what oh
hi do you need a candle can I give you a
candle who needs a candle I got a lit
candle here pretty lit if you asked me
blood candle you need blood candle oh hi
okay burn the box got a handle this
makes two this makes logical sense oh
that's a super soaker it's a super
soaker yeah it's blue oh he's gone I was
gonna sploosh real good all right who
else gets flushed
I got a sploosh Irgun it's got full of
sploosh few lies well better clean up
that mess nope it's just gonna be there
reminding me of my failures I was dream
daddy oh hi I didn't even notice you on
the first path why didn't I notice that
hello okay done another key is this one
for the doer oh hi hello friend how are
you doing good bye gotta keep going
in the darkness oh I better turn this
back on because that's important can't
see otherwise
boink yeah oh that's it then okay well
no fantastic outro for me then either
way that was playtime
that was a short experience but it was
it was good I love I actually really
liked those uh those point-and-click
style adventures especially when they're
in the pixelated style because they
remind me of deep sleep and the deep
sleep series now that was a great point
and click like adventure game I love
those it was terrifying and amazing and
if you haven't seen those yet I'll put
those links in the description below but
this reminded me of that so the
developer you got some good ear clowns
are scary
not too bad a mechanic either so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down the
comments below and as always I'll see
you
in the next video
[Music]